a new lawsuit that uses an Ohio
fertility clinic of a sperm mix-up with
heartbreaking consequences
Joseph cartellone II says he recently
found out that he is not the biological
father of his 24 year old daughter he
and his wife have since narrowed the
possible biological father to a handful
of men one of whom worked at the
hospital that helped conceive their
daughter our consumer investigative
correspondent Anna Werner is here with
more Anna how did they figure this out
you know so many people are doing this
these days his daughter gave he and his
wife home DNA kits for Christmas last
year
the test results they received a few
months later revealed this alarming
conclusion that colonies genetic history
and makeup is nowhere to be found and
his daughter's DNA it's hard to explain
the shock and agony when you find out
that someone you love and care for your
own daughter is not genetically related
to you
Joseph cartellone a says his family was
shocked to learn that he and his 24
year-old daughter are not biologically
related there's a mix of anger pain and
confusion the family's lawsuit filed on
Wednesday says card Ilona and his wife
underwent fertility treatment in 1994
with the help of three Cincinnati Health
Organization's but they now allege those
organizations were negligent and are
seeking financial damages and they also
want to know the identity of the actual
donor the castellone say with the help
of DNA test results however they believe
they have traced their daughter's real
biological father to one of roughly five
people one of those five they say worked
at the Christ Hospital the fertility
clinic and the doctors themselves need
to be accountable in a statement to CBS
News the Christ Hospital Health Network
said it's evaluating the allegations the
American Society for Reproductive
Medicine says assisted reproductive
technology is among the most highly
regulated of all medical practices in
the US but George Washington University
Law School professor Naomi Cahn
disagrees as an increasing number of
people use fertility services the
industry has outpaced regulation
cartellone a hope
his case will encourage more oversight
if there's maybe some good that can come
out of this that we can help potentially
get some things change so it doesn't
happen again then that would certainly
be helpful the Institute for
Reproductive Health has not responded to
our request for comment in addition to
not knowing the identity of his
daughter's biological father card Aloni
says he doesn't know what ultimately
happened to his sperm and whether it may
have been used to create Mb embryos with
another woman's eggs so many surprises
coming out of these DNA tests right
people are learning about family members
they never knew they had when they're
doing what looks like a fun thing yeah
DNA tests Wow mr. cartellone he's so
measure yes I've been through that